удобрение буде для Землі
на дні окопів високі бур’яни вони
встигли вирости за той час що тут під
херсоном проходить лінія фронту для
бійця з позивним Сатана це означає
місяці життя під землею
тут українські військові сплять їдять та
чекають коли ситуація зміниться усе під
пильним оком національного генія Тараса
Шевченка
солдати тут відпочивають тоді коли йде
арт обстріл двоє на горі спостерігають
решту ховаємо ця війна здебільшого війна
артилерії обстріл військами РФ обстрілу
відповідь і очікування наступного удару
така стрілянина ведеться на відстані з
метою розбити позицію супротивника
настільки щоб потім взяти її штурмом тут
у нас дуже тяжкий напрямок танковий
якщо вже ворог піде сюди то будемо
зустрічати тут
нині наступають українські військові
кілька тижнів тому вони розпочали
Контрнаступ і відбили Кілька десятків
населених пунктів проте просуваються
вкрай повільно
села які Можливо
ми туди не заходимо але їх там теж нема
Ми не заходимо щоб не піддавати зайвий
раз життя наших військовослужбовців
небезпеці отака ситуація щойно
командування вважатиме що озброєння
достатньо особовий склад готовий і з
радістю піде вперед
тим часом Ми їдемо на іншу позицію
навколо тільки випалена земля отримати
інформацію оскільки на цій ділянці
фронту задіяно зброї наданої заходом
неможливо але при цьому нам постійно
кажуть що її недостатньо для рішучого
наступу перерва після обстрілів та обід
В окопах ці солдати живуть тут теж
кілька місяців
нині тут В окопах настрій можна назвати
навіть розслабленим у боях настала
перерва але всі чекають що будь-якої
миті росіяни відновлять посилений
обстріл доти ж вони не сидять склавши
руки розповідає боєць з позивним Вікінги
цього готуємося зарваємося
вдосконалюємо свою навичку водія зброї
намагаємося отримати нові вогневі засоби
новоозброєння всюди тільки можемо На
жаль потік західного озброєння він поки
що достатньо малий і я розумію що
напевно багатьом на заході особливо там
в Німеччині Франції Великобританії
Штатах здається що Україна вже накачана
просто американською і західною зброєю
під зав'язкою по факту це зовсім не так
по факту те що ми отримуємо воно
розходиться в
штурмовій і інші елітні підрозділи і
перекидається на найбільш небезпечні
напрямки зокрема на донбаске наприклад
зараз напрямок який пріоритетним на
конкретно цій ділянці фронту за словами
воїна ситуацію покращили зокрема
американські самохідні установки м-109 а
також причіпні гаубиці м-77 разом із САО
мовляв Якщо раніше Українська артилерія
завжди поступалася зокрема через брак
боєприпасів То тепер вона може проводити
якісну контр-батарейну боротьбу та
давати відсіч російським військам
нівелюючі кількісну перевагу артилерії
противника робота
а нещодавні удари по артилерійських
базах Росії на херсонському
Миколаївському напрямку реактивними
системами залпового вогню himars на
певний час відчутно вивели супротивника
з ладу
відображаються тим що напевно періоди
часу інтенсивність середньовічних
обстрілів вона трошки падає але росіяни
також перебудовують свою логістику і
роблять висновки із уроків які їм дають
хаймерси і дальнобійна артилерія кома
отримують партнерів тому на жаль ну
війна не йде Скажімо так в нього ворота
на нашу користь це постійно процес який
міняється так за спостереженнями
українських військових порівняно з діями
на початку повномасштабного вторгнення
РФ росіяни вже змінили тактику замість
швидких бліцкригових ударів
бронетанковими групами чи колонами
техніки елітними підрозділами Вони
почали війну на виснаження по суті нині
окупанти роблять те що робили Упродовж
останніх восьми років на Донбасі
артилерії цілеспрямовано знищують всі
укріплення на певному напрямку вони
можливоють поставки під кріплень
озброєння то що до певних районів І лише
після цього відправляють танки та піхоту
і ця Тактика на жаль недостатньо
ефективна тому що росіяни просто беруть
ясен і залізо а Ми вимушені брати їх
навпаки своїм інтелектом якимось
тактичними хитрощами уловками постійно
із зміною того як ми працюємо Ну і знову
ж таки
мотивованістю тому що ми набагато більше
мотивовані ніж їхня піхота яка тут в
якості просто м'ясо яке вугілля не
зрозуміло за що
тож наразі найважливіше В окопах під
херсоном терпіння просування вперед із
великою обережністю та постійна
концентрація
виявили що у відео залетіла з колосом
яка прихиляючи